this is takayuki a cleaning supervisor
at the rail yard in Isa he's worked for
Tokyo Metro for almost 41 years and it's
his job to make sure the trains are
cleaned thoroughly
the Tokyo Metro system is famous for
being one of the cleanest Subway systems
in the world
it transports an average of about 6
million people daily and maintaining
that reputation takes both an extensive
amount of operational organization and a
ton of manpower
the cleaning staff's approach is
straightforward but uncompromising
whatever Tokyo Metro's millions of daily
passengers touch must be cleaned today
they're cleaning the train cause at the
ISA Rail Yard which they do every 15
days
the cleaners take careful measures to
ensure each nook and cranny is cleaned
then we'll head to the ginzoichioma
station located in one of the busiest
shopping areas in Tokyo Japan where they
clean the station top to bottom
there are 41 trains on the Tokyo metro
chioda line the team cleans three to
four trains a day
once a train comes into the rail yard
clean a start by picking up any Trash
they see
it takes four workers to clean the
exterior it's all done by hand and
cleaners start by hosing it down with
water and then using brushes to scrub it
with soap
stores
is
if the stain does not come off with a
brush and soap then they use a pad to
scrub It Off
next they rinse off all the soap
meanwhile other staffers clean the
interior it takes 10 workers and they
start at the top of the car and work
their way down to the bottom
[Music]
um
the first step is to clean the area
where advertisements are placed
then they clean the luggage racks and
then the wall area
they use rags and dusters to clean each
part is
cleaners then tackle the floors and
start by mopping
they also use sticks to clean crevices
near the entrance of each door
twice a year they wax the floors of each
train car
they remove all the old wax with a
polisher and then they let it dry
once it's dry they apply two coats of
Wax
it takes about an hour and a half from
the time the wax is removed to the time
the new wax dries
all together it takes workers a little
over an hour to clean the trains inside
and out once the cleaning is complete
takayuki begins his inspections
once the kawuki approves the cleaning
the trains return to service ready to
transport millions of passengers all
over again
inside the ginzaiichoma station Chicago
and kanji worked to clean the station
daily
um
has been working for Tokyo Metro since
he was 18. he got his train license at
20 and drove trains until he was 57. he
leads the team responsible for the
cleaning and security for this station
and a few others there are nine Tokyo
Metro train lines and 180 stations that
provide service to the greater Tokyo
area
foreign
inside
oh
the escalator handrails are a high touch
surface within the station and Chicago
takes Extra Care to wipe the belt with
wet washcloths she rides the escalators
up and down until they are all clean
I know
in Destiny is
Chicago is also responsible for the
dirtiest job of the day cleaning the two
restrooms in the ginzai choma station
the main cleanings happen once a day she
has been doing this work for the past 10
years
Texas
[Music]
the first thing Chicago does is check
for any large pieces of trash
if there are none she sets up a fan and
leaves it on throughout the cleaning
process efficiency is one of the key
parts of her job and the fan allows the
bathroom to dry quickly so as not to
disrupt any customers who may need to
use it
foreign
[Music]
sticks the ozone machine hose down the
toilet and turns it on
then she scrubs each toilet by hand to
make sure it's clean for the next
customer
she also cleans the walls it's important
that she's using the right tools for
each space so as not to
cross-contaminate areas
she uses a red dust cloth to clean areas
from the knees down which is called the
contamination Zone
and a green one for clean zones which
are areas above the knees such as
mirrors and sinks
foreign
is also responsible for cleaning the
barrier between the platform and the
train doors
the top part is cleaned daily while the
lower part is cleaned once a week
the staff makes sure the station
platforms and walkways are Keen for
customers
they do cleanings with brooms every day
but they also use a machine to clean the
floors twice a month
the machine works by sprinkling water
onto the floor scrubbing with a brush
and then collecting the dirty water with
a squeegee
this way there is no water left behind
and no slippery floors
foreign
also goes around daily with a shoulder
vacuum and manually vacuums up any trash
and dust he comes across especially in
hard to reach areas
[Music]
Japan has a long history with cleaning
and cleanliness that persists today
foreign
YouTube
[Music]